christine et steve habite persie sur
cure depuis une quinzaine d'années
passeports britanniques à main ce couple
d'anglais n'aurait manqué ce scrutin
pour rien au monde
mebrek site oblige les élections sont
vraiment spécial j'ai très très
important mais ce que je regrette c'est
que peut-être s'assurer la dernière fois
que j'aurai le droit de voter et de
cendre c'est terrible un désastre je
crois que les gens ne se rendent pas
compte des conséquences
cora le break je ne sais pas qui est
également conseiller municipal steve a
tenu le bureau de vote une partie de la
matinée les en cas de brick site
il ne pourra plus se présenter aux
prochaines municipales à une vingtaine
de kilomètres de là à saint père sous
vézelay les nous sommes qui sont
déplacés en famille à 46 ans peter le
fils vote pour la première fois en
france et peut être aussi la dernière
on ne sait pas si c'est continuez à
voter alors pour les élections c'est ils
ont voté jeudi là bas et qui lui serait
bizarre pour moi déjà c'est possible oui
on était petits qui reste là jusqu'à
peut-être octobre c'est tout et voit ses
justes
juste bizarre c'est sur la bbc que
carole et brian suivent ces élections
européennes même s'ils n'attendent pas
grand chose des résultats ça va pas
changer grand chose
je suis sûr de ça c'est ce qu'on voit
maintenant c'est que c'est toujours le
pays complètement divisé et autant de
gens pour briques site et autant de gens
ont construit le bauxite en bourgogne
depuis 25 ans carole et bryant un petit
fils français pour pouvoir continuer de
voter
ce couple de retraités anglais va
bientôt demander la nationalité
française